hey everyone welcome to yessi tv where
you can find weekly videos on minimalism
and healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life
today i'm going to share with you seven
life lessons that i've learned from
working with dying patients
i used to be an icu nurse did that for a
few years
and then i completely changed gears to
hospice nursing
where i now help dying patients live
their best life
for whatever time they have left during
these years i've learned so much about
life
and for me personally number one truly
is the most valuable
time our time is limited i used to take
this sound for granted
i've wasted countless hours doing
useless things that did nothing to
better myself
or anyone else's lives i've seen
children die and i've seen
adults die unexpectedly children
especially hit me hard because i am a
mother
but it teaches me that we should never
take life for granted
not my own not my loved ones and don't
get me wrong it's not about the quantity
of time that you have
but for me knowing that my time is going
to run out
that i could die tomorrow changes the
way that i live
today my time your time it's running out
that's a fact
so two main questions i want you to ask
yourself are
number one what do i want to accomplish
before i die
and number two what kind of impact do i
want to have on other people's lives
before this happens whether you like it
or not you're going to leave a legacy
behind
so what's it going to be you get to
decide
lesson number two live with purpose when
people often talk about finding their
purpose in life they talk about
finding your passion pursue your passion
but passion isn't something that you're
just
born with and that's it it's something
that molds with you that develops
as you have new experiences meet new
people and try new things
i didn't have a passion for icu nursing
actually
quite the opposite but that experience
led me to
this job that i currently do feel very
passionately about
so learn and try new things i've come to
realize that
even as insignificant as my life might
be in the grand scheme of life
i have the ability to create change i
have the option of either shutting
myself
out and keeping myself boxed up in my
own little world
or offering a service to others and
making a difference
so the lesson here is live life
purposefully and the passion will come
to you
lesson number three might be a hard one
for some of you
who have lost a loved one and it is
letting go
can be an act of love i know some of you
might look at me like
what but letting go can be one of the
most loving things you can do
when i worked in icu i specifically
remember one older gentleman
who had suffered a long battle with
cancer he was ready to go
he was at peace with it and he actually
wanted to stop
all kinds of treatments his family they
had other ideas they wanted him to
continue
everything and he didn't want that when
they finally accepted his wishes
and it was time for him to go all of his
family was around his bedside
they shared stories they laughed they
cried together
they shared pictures they combed his
hair they made him
look nice and presentable he felt good
he smiled
when it finally came time for his death
one of his
daughters looked at me and said how can
you do this for a living this is so
sad i smiled warmly and said
no this is beautiful
you are all surrounding him with love
and you're giving him
a dignified death that he would have
wanted
when a family member chooses to let
someone go naturally
instead of hanging on for their own good
and for their own benefits
that is love lesson number four is on
humility we are so fragile and whether
you're rich poor
white black or brown you will not escape
death
so we should always be humble some of my
patients live in million dollar homes
with gorgeous chandeliers
intricate furniture and acres and acres
of land
but they don't have the health to enjoy
it now don't get me wrong i don't think
it's bad to pursue wealth if you want to
make a positive impact in the world
but know that wealth comes from within
the rich man is not he who has the most
but he who needs the least
i had a very wealthy mom want to sue the
hospital because we couldn't fix her
son's
weakened heart from years of nephews
unfortunately
her money or her power was not going to
save him
i also had a racist patient had to deal
with the fact that a mexican nurse
gave him cpr and saved his life the
irony
right we are all human and we deserve
the same dignity and respect
so let's be humble lesson number five
love
every single day
this one happened almost three years ago
and it still sometimes makes me cry
a mom lying in the hospital bed with her
child
holding him tightly and caressing his
head as he took his last breath
we could not save him i don't know if
your family is broken or if you're as
happy as can be but there is
always someone in your life that you can
give love to
it can be as simple as giving an
encouraging word or helping that older
adult
carry your groceries into the car when
you give love
your brain perceives love it makes you
happier
but not only that it gives you a sense
of purpose and by focusing on
serving and loving others it can
definitely give you a greater sense of
accomplishment
for my husband and i there's not a day
that we don't tell each other by before
going to work because we don't know if
we'll be back my challenge to you is
think of
one simple thing that you can do every
day to give love to the people in your
life
it can be as simple as calling a friend
or reading a bedtime story with your
child every night
and for greater accountability let me
know in the comments what your act of
love is going to be
but keep it pg lesson number six
the bucket list i had a patient just
last week
actually a two-year-old whose battle
with brain cancer has been extremely
rough
for both her and her family and her
parents really wanted to give her the
experience of being able to go to the
beach
at least once in her life they had to
plan meticulously between tube feedings
medications
and making sure that she didn't stick
anything in her mouth because she's
immunocompromised
it was quite an ordeal for them to plan
this out and to do it safely
but the thing is they did it this little
girl got to go to the beach she got to
stick her little toesies in the sand and
feel an ocean breeze
for what might have been her last time
what is your bucket list
that thing that you've always wanted to
do that you've been putting off
i'm not saying go crazy and go bankrupt
on expensive and frivolous vacations
but enjoy and explore the world around
you make
it count lesson number seven is on fear
of failure
in my interview with entrepreneur tammy
williams
she mentions that to conquer her fear of
failure she had to acknowledge that so
long as something
isn't dead she can fix whatever she's
failed in when my husband and i started
our company
we lost 16 thousand dollars it
hurt i cried a lot because that meant
months of free labor
down the drain but you know what money
truly does come and go and i now have
learned
that failure is not something to fear
but actually something to pursue
okay surely you're thinking she's nuts i
love the saying
those who have never failed have never
tried
if there is something that you're unsure
of doing or trying
because you're afraid of failure then
ask yourself this question
if i were dying would i regret not
having tried
okay guys i could probably go on for
hours talking about the topic of death
and dying because i'm truly passionate
about giving people their best life
for whatever time they have left but i
don't want to put you to sleep
so for sticking to the end i just want
to give you one last piece of advice
be present even if you're bored and have
nothing to do
then enjoy the air that you're breathing
in because some people have pain with
every breath they take enjoy the way the
birds sing because some people can't
hear them
enjoy the way the breeze makes a leaf
move on a tree
because some people can't see it so
whatever you're doing and whoever you're
doing it with
actually be present and in the moment
that's it for today guys
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so you won't
miss out on my weekly videos
i thank you so so much for watching this
video because it's truly very special to
me
and i hope to see you in the next one